hey
then
inside
here
push down
okay and then this one
i'm going to use my body to control so
i'm going to let go
here
down here
then
collapse in
inside here
down
body controls
right here
down
body control
uh
sort of lenient with your uk but you
have to keep the angles of cancellation
okay
so
uh when i come in
this is a pin right there
i'm pinning
okay
and i i am not just here bringing it
here
there's there's a pin right there okay
do you feel that
okay and then i just ease up a little so
he can roll into place
okay
and then what i want here is body
control
body control
[Music]
there's already a pin there
then i i'm letting him get him
and it's up
to my body okay i don't want to be hand
dependent we'll get there my body is
helping me do the pin
and i catch things
not here there's no pin here
this way
then body
[Music]
right there
right there just letting them out
body
not hand dependent
when i get here
i use my whole body
you see
now my not my arm
my hip drives
you see that come back
here
hit
down
right into my chest
you see
i fall like
this
[Music]
then it goes right into place
like keep that
relationship you see
right
backward
down
now don't land here
land in it
think in it
okay
first land in it
don't land on the side of the guy
so uh when you do these pins like this
pause here you lost the gun
so you want to work with controlled
maintenance okay you don't you don't
have to go fast
but it has to be tight
you see so out here i don't have the guy
push go forward
it has to be tight so when i'm going
here i'm shoving it down go forward
you think can't go forward okay it's all
tight boom and same thing goes here go
forward
i have to land so that shoulder
mechanism is going down
around i don't have to go fast
locking it in place
i don't want you to worry about your
hands yet
i want you to get your body
home
hot down body body
finish is the same
boom
there's the pin
in
body
body in place
scapular mechanism down
control maintenance
no openings
okay
okay so i get around to get his elbow to
go down the hand goes up
hand goes up and now what i'm doing
if if i just press down his hand's going
to drop
so instead i'm using a yielding
technique around his hand so you keep it
up do you see how i keep it up then it's
in place
so i can't push on it
or i'll lose the technique
pull
right here on my body on my body not
shoving it down
i'm going around it but it's tight
then in place
so the chest has to heal
chest yields not push down here
yield
yield is in place
don't push down on it go around it
it's in place
[Music]
so again don't
become afraid you'll push on it you'll
lose it keep it by yielding it
and getting it into the next lock
so often your kid knows what's coming
and they start to roll over on you
and they roll over on you don't take
this elbow because that elbow is not
partially viable it looks like it is
okay
so even as they even as they do that you
keep that curve in place okay you keep
that curve
so this
curve we'll just show you the force
is uh just like cocunaga so here
you go you're going to use your hip
your hip
hips doing it
okay so that's what i'm taking around
here
it goes around okay
don't just use your hand like this
your hip
goes down we're just gonna shove that
things down right now so around
so we're not doing that
shove it around here
okay hip throws it all right let's try
it
that that's your mechanism
it's in
it's on
in place boom
now now your arms kind of assist you
on
i can use my arms now they're not
dependent they're supporting the
bodywork
you can go smooth if you want but don't
let him straighten that arm this way
pull
on
arms are supplemental
okay
and what we were doing was it it's on my
body pull your hand down can't pull his
head down do you see and now we're going
to do both
they're redundant but the body's primary
the arms are secondary the arms are
supplemental so i come around
goes on my body
but i put my hands in place you see
they're at the elbow and the wrist and
instead of using my hands to move him
i move my body
move him
can you see that now my hands are in
place
hands are in place you see they are in
place but they're not
primary
so i go around
body moves you see body moves
hands are there in case things go south
okay but they're in place